[Música]
bienvenidos una vez más a este espacio
sobre ciencia y tecnología en france24
soy valentina torres sánchez y es un
gusto acompañarlos esta vez desde casa a
causa de la pandemia de kobe 19
justamente iniciamos con un estudio
realizado en alemania que muestra que el
virus podría cambiar características de
los glóbulos blancos y rojos de la
sangre una vez que la persona lo ha
superado hemos escuchado hablar del co
bit largo que hace referencia a síntomas
que los recuperados mantienen a pesar de
haber vencido el virus entre los más
comunes están dolores de cabeza fatiga
falta de aire y tos pues el análisis
realizado por científicos del centro de
física y medicina max planck demuestra
que esto podría deberse a que las
células sanguíneas que les mencionaba
anteriormente sufren un daño y ya no
tienen la misma capacidad de deformación
lo que notamos principal e
inmediatamente después de la primera
medición fue que especialmente en
pacientes con enfermedad aguda los
glóbulos rojos ya no se deformaron de la
manera característica normalmente los
glóbulos rojos se estiran durante mucho
tiempo son mecánicamente muy suaves y
por lo tanto se ajustan muy bien a
través de los finos capilares sanguíneos
y en el caso de los pacientes con kobe
hemos descubierto que una gran
proporción de estas células ya no tienen
esta propiedad de deformación los
responsables del estudio exponen que los
síntomas pueden deberse a que al no
poder deformarse los glóbulos no pueden
hacer su trabajo correctamente por lo
que los nutrientes y el oxígeno nos
llegan adecuadamente a todos los órganos
del cuerpo para analizar las células
sanguíneas los expertos utilizaron un
método propio denominado citometría de
de forma habilidad en tiempo real con el
que los glóbulos son enviados a alta
velocidad a través de un estrecho canal
que estira los leucocitos o glóbulos
blancos y los eritrocitos o glóbulos
rojos una cámara de alta velocidad
registra a las células y luego un
programa determina los tipos de células
presentes su tamaño y si se deforman al
pasar con este nuevo método podemos por
primera vez registrar hasta mil células
por segundo y medir sus propiedades
mecano
en comparación con tecnologías
anteriores que median a una velocidad de
aproximadamente 100 células por hora
somos 36 mil veces más rápidos
los científicos examinaron más de 4
millones de células sanguíneas de 17
pacientes gravemente enfermos de 14
personas que se habían recuperado y de
24 sanas como grupo de comparación y
descubrieron que los glóbulos rojos de
los pacientes con la enfermedad se
diferenciaban considerablemente de los
de las personas sanas lo que indica
daños en estas células y también podría
explicar síntomas como la oclusión
vascular y las embolias pulmonares en el
centro max planck los investigadores
destacan la importancia de este tipo de
descubrimientos pues pueden ayudar a
determinar el siguiente paso para tratar
el commit según ellos sería conveniente
que empresas farmacéuticas estudian este
fenómeno y busquen formas de desarrollar
medicamentos para devolverle a los
glóbulos la capacidad de deformarse lo
que garantizaría que realicen un trabajo
eficiente al poder transportarse por el
cuerpo cambiamos de tema y vamos a
taiwán donde la ong de aliens está
probando una embarcación que recoge
basura flotante en la superficie del
agua y la almacena en un compartimiento
utiliza una cinta transportadora fijada
entre dos cascos flotantes se trata de
un proyecto que inició hace cuatro años
y que ya completó las pruebas en la
universidad nacional de taiwán este
prototipo es operado mediante un control
remoto y según los responsables sería
clave para mantener libres de basura las
áreas portuarias y el bote tiene dos
cascos lo diseñamos de esta manera para
poner una cinta transportadora entre
ellos esta cinta alcanza un metro bajo
el nivel del agua para recoger la basura
flotante la basura drena su agua en el
cinturón y acá en la cesta de atrás y
para hacer que el barco se moviera
instalamos dos motores uno en cada casco
para que gire a medida que los motores
cambian de velocidad regency
los expertos dicen que 9 millones de
toneladas de desechos incluidas botellas
de plástico
juguetes y otros artículos van
anualmente al océano desde playas ríos y
arroyos poniendo en peligro la vida
marina y el la ong indican que podrían
usar conexiones inalámbricas 5g en una
próxima generación del catamarán para
entregar datos en tiempo real a las
autoridades portuarias y finalizamos
este espacio con otra iniciativa
amigable con el medio ambiente pero
desarrollada en georgia donde la empresa
emergente te está convirtiendo tapas de
botellas en cables usb
voy a entender la tecnología para
producir cables usb e importe todas las
máquinas necesarias a georgia durante
este proceso entendí que también
necesitaba importar a georgia diferentes
polímeros plásticos que causarían daños
adicionales al medio ambiente y no
quería hacer eso eligió ham to the
market el instructor
luther el tema vital de brokers en white
entonces se me ocurrió la idea de las
tapas de botellas porque porque este
tipo de plástico está en todas partes
entendí que era una muy buena idea
usarlas para aumentar la conciencia de
los ciudadanos
to increase de awareness of my citizen
web la idea original fue evolucionando y
ahora se fabrican cables de carga
ecológicos y con materiales reciclados
en principio el fundador ofrecía un
cable a cada persona que le llevará 50
tapas de plástico y en dos meses reunió
100.000 -actualmente tenden de tres mil
cables mensualmente y ofrecen uno
gratuito si el adquirido se daña dentro
del primer año llegamos hacia el final
de este espacio pero recuerden que este
y otros programas los pueden repetir en
nuestra web france24 puntocom
[Música]